[Applaudissements]
ambiance endiablée pour ces cubains de
miami qui participe à un événement
anticommuniste
[Musique]
il chante presque tous en choeur je vote
pour donald trump une chanson créée il
ya quelques semaines seulement par
hellman pile ali sa femme et son frère
arrivé de cuba comme réfugié politique
aux états unis en 2007
[Musique]
la chanson du groupe los tres de la
habana est devenue virale surtout depuis
que l'équipe du président l'a publié sur
sa chaîne youtube
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donald trump les a remerciés en leur
envoyant quelques petits cadeaux qu'ils
arborent fièrement aujourd'hui
mais pourquoi donald trump parce qu'il
serait selon lui le dernier rempart
contre le socialisme représentés par jo
bayda
sur la calle ocho l'artère principale de
la petite à vannes de miami d'autres
cubain ne joue pas la même partition
[Musique]
mais pour pépé montes le chef du groupe
son choix est fait
[Musique]
en floride plus d'une personne sur
quatre est hispanique ou latino un bloc
qui est loin d'être homogène au niveau
politique pour s'en rendre compte il
suffit d'une bonne discussion à propos
de donald trump virginia démocrate
argentine ne le porte pas dans son coeur
rafael amargo un conseiller financier et
cubains et inscrits comme électeurs
indépendants
donald trump reste son favori impôts non
payés économie chancelante gestion de la
pandémie
le bilan du président est passée au
peigne fin né à porto rico lydia
maldonado vient de se lancer en
politique pour siéger à la législature
de floride sous la bannière républicaine
ce qui inquiète la démocrate virginia
saviez tôt c'est l'efficacité du message
de donald trump
même s'il est erronée pas de quoi
tempérer refait la marque
ce panel latino semble donner la
victoire à donald trump et fait même
hésiter la démocrate qui votera joe
biden a national identity bord dont l'a
écouté si le tempérament latin les unit
mais rien pour les empêcher d'échanger
leur numéro de téléphone
raphaël met toutefois en garde les deux
candidats à la présidence le pays
d'origine
l'histoire des latinos un impact sur la
façon dont ils voteront bon we know
[Musique]
une chose est sûre les cubains de miami
estiment qu'ils devraient voter encore
pour donald train en tout cas il faut
que le président gagne sinon son rêve
américain est menacée là dessus il est
vraiment au diapason avec son président
[Musique]
non